gibt es ihrer heimat noch leider nicht
existiert nicht mehr
nein nein
seit drei jahren muss der syrer bartl
nasser ertragen wir bomben sein
heimatland zerstören wie ist es wenn es
die heimat plötzlich nicht mehr gibt und
man nicht weiß ob man seine familie je
wieder sieht davon handelt dieser film
mio basinas ist seit fünf jahren hinter
schweiz dank seiner unterstützung
konnten seine eltern und schwestern dem
kriegen fliehen
gerade sind sie im empfangszentrum als
spiel angekommen
zehn erwachsene und sieben kinder das
ist
die zweite schwester mit ihrer familie
auch und das ist meine pflicht
verheiratete schwester vater und mutter
und das die dritte familie meine
schwester laura und jede mahnung blicken
basinas er kam in die schweiz um
islamwissenschaften zu studieren in
syrien war noch kein krieg und dann der
uni in bern verliebte er sich in daniela
die beiden wohnen in kehrsatz danielas
eltern über wochen haben sie die flucht
seiner familie organisiert sich die
ganze hat mich geglaubt die ganze sache
die ganze organisationen die sorgen die
ich trage immer tragen musste nicht
schlafen können es war absolut mühsam
alles war mühsam und war jede minute
sollte man mit dem mit dem tod oder
schnell oder und als sie rauskommen
könnte ich das nicht glaube dass sie
hier schon gekommen sind
es war eine riesige riesiger freude
wirklich dass er jetzt ist sicher dass
sie nicht dort sterben dass man etwas
für sie gemacht hat dank der schweiz
natürlich ja nach dem giftgas angriffen
ermöglichte eine gelockerte visaregelung
seiner großfamilie in die schweiz zu
kommen aber noch ist die familie nicht
komplett seine schwester verfehlt noch
sie und ihre familie wollen jetzt auch
pflichten
es hat zwei wegen wird das sterben oder
früchte und sie habe sich für die zweite
entschieden aber es könnte möglich dass
sie unterwegs um gebracht werden oder
erwischt werden oder festgenommen werden
oder vergewaltigt werden oder was auch
immer
basels vater hat kehlkopfkrebs er kann
nur mit dem stimm verstärker sprechen
deshalb tue und compostela urlaub oder
so werden sie sterben zwei jahre waren
sie insgesamt auf der flucht zuerst
innerhalb des landes bisher es im herbst
endlich in die türkei schafften und von
dort schließlich in die schweiz kamen
einmal wurden sie am checkpoint am
anfang
kontrolliert die mutter mit ihren hat
ihre das spielzeug genommen hat gemeint
ihr seid alle idioten gegen das regime
da sie aus der wisi kungen das ist ein
schon eine schuld allein dass man aus
der musik- und dann hat auf sie gespuckt
mama debbie sie lieben holmes an
rebellenhochburg ein mann der die
schleichwege kannte und die wachtposten
schmierte habe sie mitgenommen alle
zusammen auf einem kleinen lastwagen
wir wollten
[Musik]
ich habe ihn gefragt hast du angst dass
die flugzeuge hier kommen meint er ich
habe angst dass hier kommen für die
kinder bedeuten flugzeuge noch immer
bombenangriffen also am anfang wollte
sie überhaupt nicht kommen aber als ihr
mann konnte von der wasserfront ihn
bedroht habe sie haben
sie hatte die arbeit auf der messe sie
sollte raus sie haben sich alle
schwergetan weg zu gehen alle hätten sie
gute jobs gehabt als managerin lehrerin
oder wissenschaftler
basels vater war offizier zuerst
verloren sie ihre arbeit und dann eher
zu hause
10.000 dollar hätten sie für die vier
familien allein für die flucht bis in
die türkei bezahlen müssen
dieses geld hatten sie nicht mehr ohne
die hilfe von basel wäre das nicht
möglich gewesen sagen sie
[Musik]
die nasa arbeitet in einem
durchgangszentrum seinen ganzen lohn
braucht er für die schlepper seiner
familie
dank eines darlehens seiner
schwiegereltern gehe es so gerade sagt
er
aber der alptraum ist noch nicht zu ende
ich gehe eigentlich zu einem kaffee um
mit meiner schwester zu schreiben die
immer noch in syrien ist daher noch
nicht
oder da es hier noch nicht klar ob sie
diese woche in die türkei flüchten
könnte oder nicht da ihr mann sehr stark
gesucht ist der arzt war und die
rebellen immer von arts hat was können
sie für sie tun von hier organisieren
den weg eigentlich mit ein paar stepper
installieren und muss sich den weg von
fossilien also an der grenze von sillian
in die türkei auch organisieren
ich habe mit zwei schlepper bis jetzt
gesprochen und sie haben mir versprochen
sie in die türkei zu schleppen
dank des handys erhält na wenigstens
lebenszeichen von den flüchtlingen
hunderte von sms gehen in den letzten
monaten hin und her
[Musik]
rafa hat das alles wird ständig
bombardiert meinte sie und sie haben
angst dass hat gerüchte die sagt das
militär von der an der seite von
richtung türkei ich meine ist unsere
stadt angreifen und das heißt sie können
nicht mehr in die türkei und deswegen
haben sie angst
hallo man aber realistisch lange doch da
hält man aber sie war am schlafen aber
ein bandsalat irgendwie geschlagen und
oder geschosse und deswegen ist sie gott
geboten meint er
22 und er hat mir gesagt du musst alles
organisiert
sicherheitshalber flüchten sie getrennt
in der türkei hoffen sie zusammen ein
visum für die schweiz zu bekommen das
wird schwierig der bundesrat hat die
weisung für erleichterten
familiennachzug nach nur drei monaten
bereits wieder aufgehoben
die großfamilie nasse hatte also glück
ob ihre schwester rafaisz auch in die
schweiz schaffen wird ist nun wieder
sehr unsicher
die 17 verwandten sind anfang dezember
dem kanton bern zugeteilt worden
das hat verlassen sie heute als wir sie
haben sich alle persönlich auf dem
migrationsamt in bern zu melden
[Musik]
hier wird man ihnen eröffnen in welchem
durchgangszentrum sie die nächsten
monate verbringen werden
daniela bals frau spricht sehr gut
arabisch das hilft bank kennen lernen
weil sie schon so lange unterwegs waren
konnten die kinder fast drei jahren
nicht mehr zur schule gehen
jetzt müssen sie zuerst die neue sprache
lernen die ganze familie bekommt einen
sogenannten ausweis n für asylsuchende
ob sie allerdings asyl bekommen das
werden sie erst in ein paar monaten
erfahren
jetzt dürfen sie die schweiz nicht mehr
verlassen und nicht arbeiten
sie bekommen zwischen 7 und 9 franken
pro tag und person
die csu war allen aufbrechen und nachher
sofort nach 25 minuten mal schauen
nach lees also täglich müssen sie sich
auf neue situationen einstellen dass
autos tatsächlich vor einem
fussgängerstreifen anhalten ist eine
neue erfahrung
hätten sie basen nicht alles viel
schwieriger zu verstehen er übersetzt
nämlich sprache und kultur bedankt sich
bei der schweiz dass sie das sagen mich
gesehen hat meinte ok wenn sie so hier
stellt unser start das könnt ihr durch
den kopf
mit einer guten zu viel bin aber total
effektiv sie ja sie denkt dann nicht sie
ist sehr froh dass sie überhaupt da ist
in allschwil traten sie sich noch kaum
auf die straße
nur langsam nähern sie sich der konsum
welt wieder an
wann haben sie denn das letzte mal
kleider gekauft
[Musik]
während sie einmal mehr ins ungewisse
fahren sagt auch ihre schwester endlich
die flucht aus syrien
[Musik]
sie sehnen sich danach endlich irgendwo
anzukommen das durchgangsheim ließ wird
wieder ein neues zuhause auf zeit bis
sie den asyl entscheid und eine wohnung
bekommen kann es über ein jahr dauern
trotzdem freuen sie sich auf die neue
unterkunft sagen sie
aber damit haben sie nicht gerechnet
[Musik]
zwei familien und familien da was ist
dein ziel und das ist ein achter zimmer
sie können du kannst dich bereits vier
familien gibt es nur zwei zimmer
das heißt keine privatsphäre für die
frauen und männer forderungen zu stellen
verbietet ihnen eigentlich der anstand
das familienoberhaupt kann dann doch
nicht schweigen
oder vielleicht doch
basel gibt nicht so schnell auf und
tatsächlich eine halbe stunde später
gibt es eine lösung
heute heute ist montag am donnerstag
wird ein zimmer frei oder einer familie
man kann eine familie schon hoch gehen
dann ist immer noch sind immer noch zwei
familien zusammen aber wir setzen alles
daran dass bis ende monat eine lösung
besteht
versuchen sie es wollen dass das sei
eine gute lösung
dann aber setzte ihnen darf damit sie
ein bisschen erleichtert
[Musik]
anders kann man nicht sagen das muss ich
glaube bis zu 90 prozent gilt der mann
eine der serie ist ende des monats so
viel sei verraten es wird klappen
zwei wochen später hat jede familie ihr
eigenes zimmer und in der nacht kommt
die erlösende nachricht von rafah ihre
wohnzimmer ihre schlafzimmer ihr
gewohntes leben all das gibt es nicht
mehr
na was man sah von der arzt wollte lage
nicht fliehen weil er helfen wollte aber
seine praxis sieht inzwischen so aus
die situation in syrien verschlimmert
sich von monat zu monat
[Musik]
drei viertel der stadt bei uns ist auf
dem boden
meine mutter hat gemeint hat viele leute
die auf karton auf der straße schlafen
und man ist nicht mehr sicher wenn man
in einer stadt von den rebellen
kontrolliert ist in jede minute könnte
jemand wütend war sein und der einen
anderen töten oder entführen wegen geld-
oder alles alles möglich
die lage in syrien ist sehr
unübersichtlich geworden die beiden
reden oft darüber da sozusagen die
finanzierungsquellen verschiedene
finanzierungsquellen hat im land
deswegen spalteten sich immer noch die
rebellen weiter und weiter und weiter
das finde ich auch so läppisch sie haben
denn das hauptziel vergessen das land zu
befreien und angefangen geld zusammen
und waffen zu haben und was auch immer
ich meine sie sollten sich einigen und
fertig vereinigen und fertig ich das für
sie war sich sicher schwierig wenn man
so eben mit vier bandmitglieder die
räume fragt ob es ist passiert was gibt
es neues in europa und das nimmt anke um
mit der nachricht das ist wie mit dem
sofa saß deswegen achten
gefährlich ist es jetzt für ihren
schwager nach vorn er ist unterwegs
richtung türkei
dreimal muss er umkehren würden ihnen
die regierungstruppen erwischen er würde
es wohl nicht überleben
anfang januar willkommen rafah und davon
ein visum für die schweiz und fliegen
von istanbul nach zürich sie können es
alle kaum glauben
mir geht's super jetzt ich freue mich
extrem das geglaubt hat und so schnell
es hat wirklich es war wirklich schnell
überhaupt wann war hatte sie termin am
20 12 10 und gerade nach den ferien hier
in der schweiz oder nach den feiertagen
und aber sie das visum bereits gekommen
ein paar und syrische flüchtlinge sind
inzwischen in der schweiz und schon
tauchen fragen auf
dort ist ein schlag ist ein schlachtfeld
und nicht hier er ist nichts zu streute
keinen großen sinn dass ich meine wenn
jemand einen terroranschlag in europa
machen will
also die müssen nicht als flüchtlinge
hierher kommen und hier asyl beantragen
so scheint's mäßig also da gibt es sehr
viele andere wege
[Musik]
und wurde sehr stark dort bombardiert
und damit mit dem tod gerechnet
müde sein sie sagt er
die heimat in syrien gibt es nicht mehr
aber ist heimat nicht auch da wo man
willkommen ist und wo man geliebt wird
[Musik]